تخيل الهروب من الحرب الأهلية ثم
ينتهي به الأمر في الخطوط الأمامية
لمعركة أخرى في منزلك الجديد
حسن العقاد هو لاجئ سوري تحول إلى
صانع أفلام كانت رحلته المليئة بالأظافر
إلى المملكة المتحدة جزءًا من فيلم وثائقي حائز على جائزة BAFTA
لكنه الآن ينضم إلى
المعركة ضد فيروس كورونا و  العمل
كعامل نظافة في عنبر مستشفى هنا في
لندن وحساد عربة هنا
لتخبرني قصته المذهلة حسن مرحبًا بك
في البرنامج
الذي تحدثنا عنه عدة مرات من قبل
لأنني التقيت بك في العديد من
حالاتك الأخرى لجمع الأموال و
والعمل الخيري الجيد الذي تقوم به
ولكن هنا ذهبت إلى واحدة من
أخطر الأماكن الموجودة
الآن وتلك هي أجنحة المستشفى كوف إت
واردز وسط هذا الوباء
ما جعلك تفعل ذلك ، شكرًا لك على
استضافتي.  كان بحثًا بسيطًا على Google
أجريته لأنني أردت المساعدة
منذ أن بدأ الوباء وأدى هذا
البحث إلى وظيفة في
المستشفى المحلي الذي أعمل فيه والذي
يستغرق مسافة عشر دقائق حرفيًا  k من شقتي هنا في
شرق لندن ، أعلنوا عن عمال النظافة
كانوا بحاجة ماسة إلى عمال النظافة
وقد قرأت مقالات تفيد بأن الفيروس يمكن أن
يعيش على بعض الأسطح لمدة تصل إلى
أسبوعين وزملائي في موظفي NHS
يتعايشون مع الفيروس وبعض
المستشفيات لذلك  لقد اعتقدت أن التنظيف
والتطهير سيساعد زملائي
و NHS وسيساعد أيضًا
المريض على التعافي في بيئة نظيفة وآمنة ،
كيف فعلت ذلك
لأنك شعرت أنه واجبك في منزلك الجديد
، أعني أنك تقوم بعمل بطولي  الوظيفة ،
فأنت جزء من قوة العمل الأساسية
الآن ، لكنك اعتدت أن تكون مدرسًا للغة الإنجليزية ،
وكنت صانع أفلام ، وقمت
بعدد كبير من الأشياء
التي دفعتك للبحث في هذه الوظيفة الآن
، لقد قمت بكل أنواع  جميع الوظائف هي
اللغة الإنجليزية ، لقد صنعت أفلامًا ومصورًا
ولم أنظف مهنيًا مطلقًا من
قبل ، والسبب وراء رغبتي في التنظيف
هو أنني أردت أن أعتني بمجتمعي ،
فهذه هي نظري مرة أخرى
المستشفى ، هذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه جيراني
إن ابتساماتي هم الجيران وهذا هو
المستشفى الذي سأذهب إليه إذا
حدث لي شيء ما ، ليس من واجبني
أن أكون أمينًا لأن طلب اللجوء واللاجئ
هو حقوقي المنصوص عليها في القانون الدولي
ولكن بما أنني  لقد كنت هنا في لندن على
مدار السنوات الأربع الماضية ، وقد عولجت
جيدًا من قبل الأشخاص هنا
وأردت أن أساهم
وأردت دفعها عن طريق تنظيف
مستشفاي وتطهيره